now judge in the hague has ordered the
netherlands to repatriate more than 50
children of women who joined ISIL in
Syria 23 women asked the court to allow
their families to return due to
deplorable conditions in the unhold camp
in northern Syria the court found only
the children must be sent back to the
Netherlands Laurence Lee joins us live
now from The Hague so take us through
this ruling and particularly why it
found the children should come back but
not the mothers yeah there's a little
bit more to it than that let me try and
explain it is one of those rulings
that's going to be looked at very
carefully I think by several European
countries which are trying to work out
how to balance these these difficult
considerations about what about what to
do in this situation public opinion in
many European countries is very much
against these people but you know as the
judge plainly pointed out in this
hearing the children that he said should
be repatriated by the Dutch government
within 14 days the Dutch have to
demonstrate how they're going to try to
do this but the other thing that he said
in relation to the women is when whoever
goes there to try to get the children
out when they speak to the Kurdish camp
commanders if those Kurdish commanders
say you're only going to have this child
if their mother goes with them then
they've got to take the mothers as well
and so in that sense the court actually
put the onus on to the Kurds to try to
figure out what they're going to do so
in that sense for the lawyers returning
the families they're regarding it as
pretty good news even if the Dutch
government doesn't actually want to try
to bring these people back but let's
sort of someone who's been affected by
this Omar who's whose cousin is in the
camp and of course your cousin hasn't
got any children so this actually
doesn't affect her does it you
disappointed by this exact thing I'm
very disappointed about this case my
cousin she don't have children but the
condition the health condition of my
cousin is very bad this moment now a new
boost maintains that she was suffering
mental health problems when she was
before before was persuaded to go there
by exactly my cousin she traveled twice
to to Syria the first time she came back
from Syria to Amsterdam when you took
passports exactly I have the passport
here you can see it here's the passport
I took it back and we as a family we did
everything to stop her and you say it
was the police to try to specifically we
asked support from the Dutch government
from the police but nobody takes
responsibility because their answer was
yes she's not danger for herself and not
for others we can do nothing about it
and was possible for her to travel for
the second time to Syria and now do you
think she went there with the view to
fighting with ISIL who knows I can chase
nothing about it but I can say if she
was very sick before she travels she was
one year in an Medical Center and she
had medicine for her mental condition
the government they knew that and and we
asked them for support we asked him
please help us because she gonna she
gonna get to a group of beasts of
radical people who gonna abuse her
situation and we as a family did
everything we went to the police we went
to the government everything but but the
touch cabin isn't gonna make any attempt
now to bring her back at all all right
I have hope so we're gonna talk with our
lawyer about the situation and I hope
our humanity our branch she can come
back because she don't drink she don't
eat she is alone and her mental
situation is very bad this moment oh man
thank you very much today good luck with
all that the part of the problem just
just just bug just by way of wrapping up
is is really there's so many European
governments are so frightened the public
opinion in their own countries that says
we don't want these people back that
they're actually trying not to do it and
when you see what we've seen just just
the last day or two the Turkish military
literally rounding people up and
deporting them and and the lawyers for
the families here saying look the
Americans have offered to go into al
Hall camp and pick these people out and
bring them up and deport them for us
it's almost easier for these European
governments who outsource the issue than
to try to do themselves or suspect now
the Ducks are going to have to be
speaking to one of those other actors to
see about getting all these children
back
thanks so much Florence Lee there